Today we discuss the idea of capital.
Now, you may have learned in economics
class that capital means money or
wealth.
What I want to argue to you today is
that capital is really a mechanism to
extract energy from you.
Okay?
And what's important to understand is
that in a universe
where consciousness
is the universe,
then what energy is ultimately is
attention and focus.
Okay?
So, it's not enough for you to work at
something, you also have to concentrate
on it in order for capital to extract
energy from you.
Okay? All right.
So, with this in mind, um let's discuss
an example, all right?
Okay? So, the most basic example is you
have a landlord class
and they're trying to extract energy
from the peasant class.
Okay?
Now,
before, traditionally, we would have
assumed energy as maybe grain.
Okay? Grain.
>> [snorts]
>> Capital.
But,
um the problem with this is you're
actually not that not that extracting
that much energy from a peasant because
it's not that hard to grow grain. Also,
grain can be stored.
Okay?
So, in other words, as a landlord, your
priority is not necessarily just to um
extract rent from the peasant, your
priority is somehow to get the peasant
to focus entirely on the task at hand.
And to do that, over the centuries, uh
landlords have figured out certain ways
or certain mechanisms in order to
extract the most value from the peasant
class.
Okay? So, let's discuss the mechanisms.
The first is that we've transitioned
from slavery
to freedom. [snorts]
Okay? If you really want to extract
value, if you really don't want to
extract energy and attention and focus,
it's much better to give peasants the
illusion of freedom rather than just
enslave them.
Okay? So, give peasants the belief that
they control over their lives. Another
word for freedom is equity, right?
Equity.
So, think of a company where I'm going
to give you some equity and then you
work a lot harder because you think you
can more make more money.
And so, this is the first trick that
we've learned over the centuries. The
second trick
is to make capital
more abstract.
Okay?
So, the abstraction of capital.
So, let's use an example. Okay, grain
was uh initially capital.
Uh the problem with grain is that you
only need so much. So, as a peasant, you
only want to work as much as necessary
in order to grow grain to feed your
family. And maybe a little bit more to
save.
But, most of the time, you just want to
enjoy your life.
But, then we transitioned to gold,
right?
>> [clears throat]
>> And gold, yeah, people are more greedy.
But, the problem with gold is there's
only a finite amount of it, all right?
It's hard to locate. So, only a minority
would expand all their energy trying to
locate gold.
And and now what we've done is we've
transitioned to the idea of money.
Okay? As I will show you, the great
innovation of the past 100 years is to
convince people that money is God.
Money is both nothing and everything,
and so you can spend your entire life
dedicated to achieving money.
Okay?
So, that's the second great innovation.
And the third great um
technique that's changed
uh economics
is to understand that if you really want
people to focus their energies,
you need to create anxiety in them.
Okay? Anxiety.
And how do you create anxiety?
Well,
the um best way is to create the idea of
debt,
right?
So, I'll lend you a million dollars
today
and you enjoy it, but then you have to
spend the rest of time paying it back.
The problem with this, of course, is
that there's interest, and so you can
never really pay it back, which causes
anxiety.
And so, the idea of debt, I can extract
much more value than from you than if
you were not in debt. Okay? That's the
first tool. Second is the idea of
inequality
and poverty
where
a certain class of people are poor and
they'll always be poor. And that
incentivizes
encourages the middle class to work even
harder.
All right?
Um the third mechanism of anxiety is
wealth destruction.
What is wealth destruction? Simple, war
or depression, right?
When the economy collapses,
when all your wealth vanishes.
The idea here is, listen, if the
peasants work really hard and they store
up a lot of grain, they have a huge
grainery, they wouldn't have to work
anymore, right? So, as a landlord, what
do you do? Well, you go burn down the
grainery.
All right? So, war is not just a
mechanism to expand capitalism, but it's
also a way to make people more anxious
uh because you destroyed their wealth
and therefore they have to work a lot
harder.
Okay? So, again,
um
in economics class, you may taught
that
>> [clears throat]
>> the point of capitalism is to accumulate
more capital. No, no, no, guys. The
point of capitalism is to focus the
energies of the peasants.
Okay? Because the attention, the focus,
is what makes a society much more
energetic.
And that's the end goal.
All right? So, so if a society is
wealthy, that's actually a good thing
because it makes people lazy and
complacent. And so, the way to resolve
this issue is by constantly engaging in
wars and by having the boom-bust cycle
that you might learn in economics class,
right? So, in economics you might learn
that the boom-bust cycle is natural to
capitalism. It is not natural to
capitalism. It is artificial. The people
in charge um artificially destroy
economies, destroy wealth to make the
peasants work a lot harder.
Okay?
So, are you guys following along? Okay?
So, that's the
strategy that we've learned
um these past few centuries. And that's
why in today's society, we are the
wealthiest
society ever in human history, and yet
at the same time we are the most
miserable, we are the most anxious, and
we are the most in debt. Okay? Because
the landlord class, the capitalists, the
elite, what they figured out are three
mechanisms in which to extract as much
energy from us as possible.
First is to give give us the illusion
that we have freedom in our lives, we
have the freedom of choice, we have
equity in society, we can vote for our
leaders. When in reality, it's all just
an illusion. Okay? Second is to make
money God, the end all and be all, both
nothing and everything,
the very focus of your life.
And because money is so abstract, you
can spend your entire life trying to
achieve more and more of it, and yet at
the same time
achieve nothing and nothing. Okay? So,
think of like someone like Jack Ma, who
has like more money than he can possibly
spend, and what does he want? He wants
more money.
Okay? And the third is to create anxiety
in society so that people's entire
existence is one of stress.
And as a result, people are much more
focused
on work
and wealth creation. And you do that by
a constant process of wealth
destruction.
All right? So, but the problem, of
course, is that when you push people too
hard, when it becomes so obvious you're
exploiting people, then people will
eventually revolt against you.
So, the solution that we figured out is
what we can do is we can actually move,
okay? The landlord class can actually
move somewhere else.
And so, when the anxiety becomes
overwhelming, what will happen is the
peasants will destroy each other
where and the landlord moves somewhere
else with the capital and they'll come
back when the peasant class have
completely exhausted themselves and
they're willing they're willing to
rebuild society. Okay? And this process
is what rules the world today. It is
what we call transnational capital.
In other words, the wealthy people
of the world, they have actually no
loyalty to nation or to people or to
place. They only have loyalty to their
capital and they're willing to move to
wherever they can, wherever they have to
in order to
keep their capital safe and to grow it.
And that's why a lot of people today are
moving to Dubai
or Hong Kong or Singapore. They don't
care. They may not be all that place,
but they'll go wherever
uh
they need to in order to pay less taxes
in order to avoid the social conflict
created by their policies.
Okay, in order to find better investment
opportunities.
And that's this system is what rules the
world today.
But then the question is, okay, in
concrete terms, what really is
transnational capital? What allows
transnational capital to function, to be
able to move from place to place?
Because remember, when you move from
place to place, there are a lot of costs
involved. For example, you don't really
know anyone there and so how can you
trust the people?
Right? And the solution that we've
developed over the centuries is the idea
of secret societies.
>> [snorts]
>> So, what you will learn is that secret
societies and transnational capital are
essentially the same thing, okay? And
this is the force that rules the world
today.
All right.
So, now that I've discussed
transnational capital, let's look at
secret societies, like where they come
from and how they work. Okay. Well,
secret societies exist because the
learner class and the peasant class are
fundamentally different. Therefore,
um their motivations, their beliefs,
their world view of these two two
classes must be different. Okay, so the
peasants. What do the peasants want?
They want to live a simple life. They
want to make some money. They want to
have a family. They want to have some
fun. They want to believe in God. Okay?
And so for the peasant class, we have
organized religion, whether it's Islam
or Christianity.
Okay, Christianity.
Jesus, right? Jesus tells you to be a
good person. Confucius tells you to be
good to be a good person.
Right? But the learner class is
different.
They have a responsibility. They have a
obligation to control
the peasant class and extract as much
energy as possible in order to maintain
their society.
Okay? So, their religious practices must
be very different. So, whereas the
peasants can pray to God, the learner
class must fundamentally pray to Satan.
Okay? So, now let's look at why the
learner class must pray to Satan. And
this is true for all societies
throughout human history.
Before the learner class was blatant
about it, okay? Now they have to be more
hypocritical, more secretive about it.
All right, so let's look at the learner
class.
All right. So, to be a learner class, to
be the elite, you have to do terrible
things.
But it's actually hard to do terrible
things. All right, so let me give an
example. Let's just say
I would say to you, all right, I'm going
to give you 10 million US dollars.
What you need to do is this. What you
need to do is take a gun
and late at night go kill a random
stranger.
You think, wow, that's a really good
deal. If I kill a random stranger at
late at night, no one's going to know I
did it and I walk away with 10 million
dollars.
And you think that I can do it, but
guess what? When I actually make you and
go make you go do it, you actually can't
do it because there are lots of um
restrictions on your behavior, okay? So,
think of suicide. If if I give you 100
million dollars and promised you
um a path to heaven, would you kill
yourself? Probably not, okay? So,
suicide
killing yourself, in many ways it's no
different from killing someone else. We
can't do it.
Okay? But there are actually hacks
around this. We've got ways to make you
go kill someone
in a way that doesn't make you feel that
guilty about it, okay? So, to understand
why, I want to introduce you two social
science experiments that they conducted
in America at the end of the 20th
century, okay? The first is something
called the
um
Milgram experiment.
Um and this was done at Yale by a
psychologist named Stanley Milgram. And
and the experiment was very simple. What
he would do is he would set up an actor,
okay? This is an actor, okay? Or we'll
call confederate.
And the person would be hooked up to an
electric chair.
Right?
And there'd be a buzzer.
A buzzer
which increases the voltage on the
electric chair, okay? And there's
there's like a max and there's a min.
Okay?
And Stanley
Milgram would be here in his lab coat.
And he would invite a participant, okay?
Who's essentially a student to come and
be an assistant, okay? And the
assistant's job was to press the button.
And Stanley Milgram wanted to know,
first of all, would
this volunteer, this assistant, agree to
shock another human being
even though he's seen the human being in
pain. And second of all, Stanley Milgram
wanted to see how much pain the
volunteer was willing to inflict.
And it turned out that with the idea of
authority, okay?
People are much more willing
to
let go of their inhibitions. Because
what you're doing is you are removing
responsibility from yourself to someone
else. I didn't do it. I was ordered to
do it. And surprisingly, people are
willing to inflict a lot of pain on
other people
because they are able to remove
responsibility for their individual
actions, okay?
Okay, does that make sense? So, the
point of secret society is to for people
to come together
and
avoid taking responsibility for their
actions. How? By praying to another god,
right? By saying, we didn't do this. We
didn't go start this war. We didn't
destroy the economy. It was Satan that
told us to do it. We had a meeting with
Satan. We did the rituals. We summoned
Satan and Satan says, for the good of
the world, you must be evil. You must go
and start this war so that we can create
paradise on Earth. It wasn't us. It was
not us. It was Satan who did this. Okay?
That's the point of a secret society.
To
um
force yourself to believe that you have
no agency in this world and you are
controlled by Satan.
Okay? Or another god, Saturn.
Okay? So, it's very common for these
secret societies to believe in a god
called Saturn. Who is Saturn? Saturn,
uh the Greek is Cronus. And
Cronus is a god of time. God Cronus is a
god of time and order and structure.
And Cronus would do things that were
unconscionable, that were inhumane
in order to maintain control of the
world, including eating his own
children. Because then his children
could not rebel against him, okay? So,
they pray to Saturn to look for that
divine energy in order to maintain order
and control in the world for the good of
others, okay? Not for the good of me,
but for the good of others.
Does that make sense? Okay? That's the
first idea I need you to understand
about these secret societies. They
always pray to a higher god. They
believe in
interdimensional lizard people or they
believe in Satan or they believe in
Saturn. Who cares, okay? But it's they
don't feel as though they're controlled.
They feel as possessed by demons or by
extra extra-terrestrials, okay? And why?
In order to do what they must to
maintain their power and their wealth.
Okay, that's number one.
Number two is this. Another experiment
that you guys might have heard of is
something called the Solomon Asch
experiment.
Okay?
>> [snorts]
>> And here, the experiment is 10 people in
a room.
Two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10, okay? And
all sit together and they're asked to
tell me if this is a straight line or a
circle.
Okay? It's that simple.
Then what happens is a volunteer
is asked to come into the room, okay?
And this volunteer goes last.
And everyone around the room goes and
tells the answer, okay?
And from one to 10, okay? And these are
all confederates, okay? These are all
part of a conspiracy. From one to 10,
they all say this is a circle.
And so, by the time you get to the
volunteer, who's number 11, he's like,
>> [snorts]
>> hm
What should I what should I say? And
often a lot of times is he'll say it's a
circle because he's trying to conform to
the group. But not only that,
afterwards,
when he's told that, oh, this is
actually a lie, he's actually convinced
he saw a circle.
Okay? That's the power of group
conformity.
Okay? So, two ideas, authority
and conformity is what underlies the
power of secret societies.
And as such,
you are now, because you are part of a
society, you now have the power to take
a gun, go kill someone late at night,
and collect your $10 million. Okay?
Does that make sense, guys?
All right. And again,
every society does this because
often, when you're part of a lower
class, the elite, the transnational
capitalists, you have to do things
against your own hardwired wiring, okay?
Your own psychology. And that's why
secret societies exist.
All right.
>> [clears throat]
>> Now, sometimes secret societies are
forced to do really bad things because
they're often in competition with each
other. And in this competition, it's
always a question of like, who's more
evil? Okay?
So, what they figured out is this.
They figured out how to structure this
their secret societies, okay? This
hierarchy.
Sorry, hierarchy.
Okay? So, these are the people at the
top, the landlords.
And these are basically the initiates,
okay? The people who want to join. But
they are ignorant about the true purpose
of this society. So, the question then
is, how do you maintain this hierarchy?
And what they figured out is something
really, really simple, all right? It's
really simple human psychology.
Throughout human history, what was very
common was for groups of young men,
okay? They've been discarded by their
families because the families don't have
enough to eat, so they get together and
they form like wolf packs. They go
around, and they're And what they really
want is a wife. Okay? That's what they
really want. More than food, they want a
wife. So, what they're forced to do is
go as a group, as a gang,
go at to a village and kidnap the woman
and kill the family, okay?
And this is a very common thing in human
history.
And let's try to figure out the
psychology of what's going on, okay? So,
you have like five guys. I This is This
is just This is just a five-man group,
okay? Five guys.
Young guys.
And they're going to go and they're
going to go to a village where there's a
family, okay? A husband, a wife, and two
kids.
What they're going to do, of course, is
they're obviously going to kill
the husband, and they're also going to
kill the two children, okay? And they're
going to kidnap the wife.
Now, let me ask you this question.
Let's understand the psychology of this
woman when her entire life is destroyed,
okay? Does she A,
want vengeance?
B, become depressed?
C,
um fall in love
with one of the guys?
A, B, or C, guys?
A, B, or C? Yeah.
What What What What is that? A. Okay.
You would You guys would think you she
would want vengeance for what happened,
but that's not what happens, okay?
What's more likely that she becomes
depressed or she falls in love. It's
often It's often a time that she falls
in love. We call this the Stockholm
syndrome.
All right. It's a very basic human
psychology that's consistent throughout
human history, throughout all societies.
When a woman sees her entire life
collapse like that, she now has no She
has no longer any stability. Her reality
is destroyed, and therefore, she clings
to anyone
who is willing to support her.
Even though that person is the person
person who destroyed her life in the
first place. It's really weird
psychology, but it's very, very true.
That's also why arranged marriages work,
okay? Throughout human society, a man a
man older man is often paired with a
younger wife. She might be like 14 or
13, but you know, after a few years,
they do fall in love with each other
because the woman is completely
dependent on the man, okay? And also
that physical intimacy.
All right. So,
um it sounds really depressing, but this
is a very basic principle of human
psychology.
Where because I I At this At this
point in history when her reality has
collapsed, her soul has left her, okay?
And now she's basically a slave.
And what a slave does is someone who
clings to life.
All right. Does that make sense? Okay.
Now, what happens to these five guys,
okay? A, do they feel guilty for what
they do?
B, do they fight over the woman? Or C,
are they brothers forever?
The obvious answer is C, right? They're
brothers forever, okay? So, even though
they commit this terrible, terrible act,
what?
Um it's made them more unified, okay?
And this is the structure of secret
societies.
The structure of secret societies is for
the people at the very top to commit
these rituals
of torture in order to turn the
initiates into slaves. And those who are
most willing
to participate in these rituals, those
who are most willing to become slaves,
become
um the middle people, okay?
The people that are most trusted.
Because now they're slaves.
And that's how secret societies work.
And that's why there are so many
different degrees of secret societies,
and that's why at the very top, no one
knows what they're really doing. What
they're really doing is praying to
Satan, okay? Because Satan is giving
them the strength, or Saturn, who Who
knows? Okay? Or whatever. Um
Saturn Saturn or Satan is giving them
the strength in order to torture
these
uh initiates so these initiates become
their slaves for life. And then these
initiates are given limitless wealth and
power because they are now completely
loyal, dependent
on
uh the master.
All right.
All right. This sounds confusing, but
let's But let's use another example, all
right? The Spartans.
Sparta.
So, Sparta Remember, Sparta is a war
society, a military society that's
intent on maintaining control over its
slaves, okay? The helots. The helots
outnumber the Spartans 10 to 1. So,
these Spartans need to be really
cohesive as a society. They need to
fight and die for each other. So, their
education system is set up like this.
At 5 or 6,
the child
the Spartan child is taken away
from the parents, okay? And this
obviously creates fear and anxiety.
All right.
Also, what happens is the child
is in school being beat up by the older
kids. And this creates
trauma, all right?
Another word we use for this is
intergenerational trauma because the
Spartans do this to every child.
Intergenerational trauma.
>> [snorts]
>> All right. So, the kid at this point is
unsafe, insecure. His mind is really
screwed up.
And then when he's most vulnerable,
maybe when he's 11 or 12,
what happens now is he's paired with an
older man who's like 29 or 30.
Okay? An older man.
And this older man, they become lovers.
Basically, what happens is the man
first, of course,
can
commits,
you know,
sexual abuse.
But again, because the child is
traumatized,
because the child has no bearings, no
reality, doesn't believe anyone in this
world loves him, even even though the
man is being abusive to him, he falls in
love with the man. And as a result, the
boy will do anything that the man orders
him to do, okay? So, what happens is
this man becomes his general,
and he becomes a soldier or an officer.
And that's why the Spartans are so
fearless.
Okay? Because the soldiers are
completely loyal to the generals because
they were once lovers. The soldier feels
as though this general, who I must obey,
he saved my life when I most needed it.
My parents abandoned me. When I was
being beat up every day. When I felt
complete insecurity, when I was
traumatized, he came and he gave me a
home, and therefore, I must die for him.
Okay? And guys, guys, look Listen. This
sounds weird, but if you go to the inner
city gangs,
inner city gangs
in America or anywhere in the world,
okay? These drug cartels in Mexico. They
use the same principles
as the Spartans.
Okay? These young boys, 13 14, they have
no fathers. They're put in a gang,
they're abused, and then the gang leader
treats them well,
uh they might have some, you know,
you know, sex, and then these boys are
completely loyal to the gang leaders.
Same thing if you go to these
these um child armies in Africa, okay?
Very basic principle that every every
human understands.
If you abuse a child and then be nice to
that child, that child is obedient to
you forever. This is how secret
societies behave, okay?
One last example.
Okay. So, in history, there was a very
famous secret society called the
assassins.
You may have played the video game
Assassin's Creed, okay?
Why are they called assassins? Because
of the word hashish.
Hashish is a chocolate marijuana, right?
It's a hallucinogen.
So, the way these societies would work
is if you're a new member, I would make
you have hashish, okay? Hashish. And and
your mind would become blurry. You feel
as though you're in a dream.
And then what would happen is I put you
in a room and you're basically like
drunk, okay? And then these young women
would come and pleasure you.
And then
you would wake up
in your home and you would think this
was a dream, okay? And your master would
tell you
this is what paradise is like.
All right? This is what heaven is like.
If you do what I tell you,
I guarantee you you will go to heaven
where 10,000 virgins will pleasure you
for all of eternity.
Okay? And this turns these assassins
into
the most dedicated killers. Again, I
keep on saying this, it's really hard to
convince someone to go kill another
person. But these assassins are willing
to do whatever it takes in order to
enter paradise.
Okay? So,
guys, this combination sex plus trauma
plus
um hallucinogens or
uh
hallucinogens psychedelics, okay? These
three things, psychedelics
drugs, sex plus trauma. They create the
perfect slaves.
Okay? Slaves.
Because now what you can do is you can
take these slaves and then have them
infiltrate other secret society. They
become the perfect spies because they
are forever loyal to you.
Okay? They're completely emotionally
dependent on you and they will do
everything what it takes in order to
please you.
But you have to you have to like
train them from an early age.
Okay? And this is and this is how these
secret societies they fight each other.
They recruit an army of young kids, they
traumatize, brutalize these kids to
train them to be spies, to be killers,
and then they will unleash these
um
kids on other secret secret societies
and their enemies as well. Like the
assassins did, okay? Does that make
sense?
Um okay, you have a question?
So, like for the woman, like her
family's all being killed, like
won't he won't she remember like who has
done like who has killed all her
families but just have relied on that
murderer because he does he he's, you
know,
Okay, I I just want to answer your
question. It's a good question, okay?
The answer is this. In psychology what
you learn is that when you're
traumatized, what happens to you?
What happens to you? You're not there.
You're it's it's What is disassociation?
Okay? You don't you're not there. You
don't remember anything because your
mind would explode or your system would
collapse if you actually remember in
detail what happened. So, your mind
disassociates. You're not there. You
don't remember anything, okay? That's
why trauma is so effective. Because not
only do you become obedient and
dependent on the person traumatizing
you, but at the same time you actually
don't remember disassociation,
okay?
So, the person who controls you, you
forget.
Your handler, okay? Your handler
is someone that is at the back of your
mind. But
even if you don't know that person, what
happens if that person comes before you
and tells you what to do, you obey.
Okay? It's almost as though the handler
has programmed you and only he knows the
password. So, this is what we call
programming.
>> [snorts]
>> And that's what they did with MK Ultra.
Okay?
MK Ultra MK Monarch. Okay? But it's a
very common thing. We've been doing this
for thousands of years in every single
society because it works and it's easy
and it's effective, okay?
All right? Does that make sense?
All right.
All right. So, let's talk about
the
development of transnational capital.
All right? So, there have been four
distinct stages.
Let's look at them.
These four distinct stages are
Venice,
Dutch Republic,
England,
and what's the last one, guys?
Come on.
America, right?
Okay.
So,
these four places are special because
they are all merchant oligarchies.
Okay? Merchant oligarchies.
Meaning that they are controlled by
private interests.
Private interests. Now, I understand
that in school you're taught that
America's democracy and England's
democracy and all that. No, guys, it's
all nonsense. These are oligarchies.
They're controlled by private interests.
They've always been controlled by
private private interests. They're still
controlled by private interests today,
okay? And the way that these private
interests what they do to maintain
control
over their people and the world is
through three mechanisms, okay? The
first is banking.
Banking just means that these oligarchs
are pooling their resources together
in order to extract energy from the
world. Now, the thing about banking
that's very important is that if you are
able to bank in a certain way, you're
able to extract energy across time and
space.
Right? You're able to borrow money from
the future and spend it today. Does that
make sense?
Okay? And this will happen with the
um abstraction of capital.
All right? So, banking is basically
um
extract time and space.
You're extracting energy from across
time and space.
Okay? I'll explain more as we go along,
okay?
Secondly is the idea of a navy
where you're where you're controlling
trade.
And the third is diplomacy.
Now, the idea of diplomacy is you don't
want to fight wars because your
population is very limited. What you
want to do is trick other people into
fighting wars for you.
Okay? You want to have these trade
negotiations. So, it's like spying,
intelligence.
All right? And in all four, what's
really important is that if you're a
merchant oligarchy, you're actually
controlled by secret society.
Okay? Not a king but by secret society.
Because otherwise, how else can these
merchants get along with each other,
okay? So, secret secret societies is
what allows them to work together to
plan and control their populations.
Now, [snorts]
what's going to happen is this.
Um Venice is
one of the early
um oligarchies, but with each iteration
it's going to improve in power. Why?
Because by the time we get from Venice
to England and
Sorry. To England and the Dutch
Republic, we have something called the
Protestant Reformation.
Okay? So, uh what I will what I will do
is explain to you what the Protestant
Reformation is.
The Protestant Reformation radically
changes
how we see ourselves and our
relationship with God, which makes
transnational capital much more
powerful.
And then what's going to happen is when
we hit England, we go from England to
America, we have the Enlightenment.
Okay?
And when we hit the Enlightenment,
what's going to happen is by getting rid
of God, we turn money into God.
And when this happens, transnational
capital becomes all powerful.
All right? So,
um remember what's happening is we have
Venice, then then the Dutch Dutch
Republic was more powerful than Venice
because it adopts the ideas of
Protestant Reformation. And then America
becomes more powerful than England
because it adopts the ideas of the
Enlightenment. What's happening
throughout this process is transnational
capital is is becoming much more
abstract and therefore much more
powerful.
Okay? And therefore much more capable of
extracting energy from the population.
All right? So, let's go over the the
Protestant Reformation.
All right.
>> [clears throat]
>> The Catholics and the Protestants. So,
there are three major differences
between the Catholics and the
Protestants.
Okay? The first So, the Catholics have
three main basic ideas, right? There's
orthodoxy.
There is hierarchy.
And there's just just justification by
works.
All right? So, the idea is, "Hey, if you
want to go to heaven, just obey the
Catholic Church. What the priest tells
you." Don't think, just do what the
priest tells you to do. Really simple,
right?
Okay, but there are three problems with
all this, okay?
The first problem is
God becomes distant from you, okay?
You're not allowed to communicate with
God.
And as I keep on saying in this class,
we humans are first and foremost
religious. We want to be spiritual. We
want to have communion with God. But the
Catholic Church says, "No, you have to
obey us, okay? You You have to obey our
dogma, even though our dogma doesn't
really make much sense."
Okay? That if hierarchy, of course,
leads to corruption, where the priests
can do what what they want
because they are in power, okay? And
they become extremely wealthy
and powerful. Now, the third problem
Just Just take a Just take a Just take a
Just take a Just take a Just take a Just
take a Just take a Just take a Just take
a Just take a Just take a Just take a
Just take a Just take a Just take a Just
take a Just take a Just take a Just take
a Just take a Just take a Just take a
Just take a Just take a Just take a Just
take a Just take a Just take a Just TAKE
A JUST TAKE a Just take a Just take a
Just take a
All right? So, that's why the
Protestants
hated the Catholic Church. And so, they
proposed a new system.
All right? The new system is, first of
all,
direct access.
You don't have to go through the priests
anymore. You don't have to listen to the
dogma of the church. You can just
actually communicate with the God
directly through the Bible, okay? Second
idea is egaltarian, where there is no
longer any hierarchy. You can
communicate with God directly. Okay? And
the third idea is justification by
faith.
Okay.
The problem though, of course, is that
these three solutions to the Catholic
problem will create more problems, okay?
The first is that of direct access.
So, you can access God directly. The
problem is that Christians believe in
the Holy Trinity.
Okay? The Holy Trinity, right? God,
Jesus,
and the Holy Spirit
are different, but the same.
Okay? Separate, but co-equal. It makes
no sense whatsoever. And as such, if
you're trying to access
yourself, you can't do it because this
force This precludes you, okay? It is
impossible for you to insert yourself
into the story of the Holy Trinity. If
it was just Jesus, you could talk to
Jesus.
But how do you talk to Jesus, God, and
the Holy Spirit at the same time? You
can't do it, okay? So, this causes
confusion, okay? Second problem is the
idea of egaltarian. This causes just
just so much chaos, debating chaos,
right? Because now, hey, if I want to, I
can start my own religion. I don't need
to
get people to agree with me. I need to
start my own religion and have followers
follow me, okay? So, this causes a lot
of debate within the Protestant
religion. It still happens today, where
among the Protestants, there are like
thousands and thousands of different
branches, okay?
The last problem is the most
problematic. Justification by faith.
This creates anxiety.
Right? Because if you don't really know
God because of the Holy Trinity, how do
you know you really believe in God?
Right? The Catholics believe that all
you do is give some money, do some good
work, don't sin, and you go to heaven.
But the
Protestants believe that no, you have to
really believe in God in order to go to
heaven.
Okay?
What's even worse is that another
reformer named John Calvin,
um he put up proposed the idea of double
pre-predestination.
Because the Catholic Church says, "You
know what?
Only we can decide who goes to heaven.
So, if you disobey us, you'll burn in
hell." And John Calvin, to respond to
this, says, "No, no, no.
The Catholic Church has no power over
anyone because God, at the beginning of
time, has already decided
who will go to heaven and who will go to
hell, okay? Double predestination. It's
already been decided, guys. And how do
you know
if Well, the solution is through energy,
right?
If you work hard and you make a lot of
money, you become very wealthy,
then you know that God favors you.
But after you become very wealthy,
what's really important is for you to
understand you can't spend any of this
money because you can't sin.
Okay? So, you can only invest the money.
All right? As you As you can understand,
the merchant oligarchies love this
because now they're taking people's
money and they're able to invest it in
any way they want. It's all going in the
bank.
Okay? And this is the Dutch Republic.
This creates the Dutch Republic,
which becomes the wealthiest society
in
Europe at this time, in the 17th
century.
Okay?
All right? Any questions so far?
Okay. So, what's going to happen though
is
by the time you go from England to
America, okay? England is also
Protestant.
The Protestant Reformation is going to
change to the Enlightenment. The
Enlightenment is There may be a God, but
God doesn't really interfere in the
universe. God lets us do what we want.
Okay? So, it's up to us create our own
world. So, now that God has left,
what happens is you need something to
replace the God, right? This becomes the
holy This becomes money, okay?
Money as God. And this works because
if you insert money into the Protestant
faith, it solves a lot of problems. It
solves the problem of anxiety because
how do you know you go to heaven? If you
become very wealthy,
okay? And
everyone, how do you know you're favored
by God? Whoever is becomes the
wealthiest, okay? So, money becomes the
new religion of America. And this is
what ultimately leads to the triumph of
transnational capitalism, okay?
All right.
Okay. So, how do we get from the Dutch
Republic to England?
Okay. The The answer is very simple. The
problem is that the Dutch Republic, it
is on the continent of Europe.
Therefore, it's very easy to invade.
They have a problem, like how do you
keep your money safe
from invaders, okay? Because they have a
lot of gold.
And so, what they will do is they will
trans They will take this money and in
1688, they will transfer most of this
money to England, okay?
So, how does England convince the Dutch
to invest in England? Well, first thing
is they make a Dutch aristocrat, William
of Orange, the king of England, okay?
All right? 1688,
England invites
William of Orange to become the king of
England. That's number one.
Number two is
the Bank of England
is set up in 1694.
What makes the Bank of England special
is that it is a private bank that is
guaranteed
by Parliament.
Okay? Does that make sense, guys? What
this means is this. What What this means
is that
if I make a lot of money, I keep it. But
if I lose my money, the people will
ensure that I get it back.
Okay? Now, what's going to happen is the
Bank of England will lend money to to
England to fight wars. Remember, the
Bank of England, what it is, it's
transnational capital.
So, it's private interest, but anyone
can invest in it, including the Dutch
Republic, including, guess what? The
Catholic Church.
Okay?
The third thing,
um is
secret societies.
So, what's going to happen is that
secret societies are going to create
these linkages among these different
transnational capital groups in order to
allow allow them to work together, okay?
All right? So, does that make sense? And
what's really important is this system
will transfer over to America,
creating the system that we have today.
The Bank of England becomes the Federal
Reserve.
Secret societies transfer over. These
are the Freemasons,
okay?
Um
All right?
Does that make sense, guys?
And this is why we have the system that
we have today.
The thing that you need You need to
understand about the Federal Reserve is
the Federal Reserve
was set up in like 1913 or 14, I can't
remember, okay? But the Federal Reserve,
what they can do is print money. It's a
private bank. It's private interest.
They print money. And the government How
How How's it going to spend money? It
borrows from the Federal Reserve at
interest.
Okay? So, the people are borrowing from
the bankers.
And so, that's why America is controlled
by private interests.
All right?
Clear?
And that's why transnational capital
controls America and the world.
Any questions?
All right. So, let's go over the PPT,
okay?
All right. So, Venice. What makes Venice
special is, after Rome collapses, the
Roman
The Roman Empire collapses, right? These
noble families, they're now
impoverished. They go to different
places.
The city that becomes dominant in the
entire peninsula is actually Venice.
Why? Because it's surrounded by marshes.
So, it's hard to invade. And you know
why actually no one invaded? Because it
has no resources.
Its only advantage is that it's by the
coast, which allows it to engage in
piracy,
as well as trade and diplomacy, okay?
All right? So, this is Venice today.
And as you can [snorts] see,
um it would be very hard to invade.
Also, remember at this time, it's very
poor, so no no one wants to invade it.
All right. Another picture. Pretty
beautiful, right?
You guys should go before um
it sinks, okay?
>> [laughter]
>> If you want to go visit Venice, do it
now before it sinks. All right. So,
again, a Venice it's a merchant
oligarchy, just like the Dutch Republic,
just like England, just like America,
okay?
It seemed like a democracy because it's
a republic, but it's actually controlled
by private interests.
Okay?
All right. So, because Venice has no
resources, it has to engage in trade.
And it's going to help set up a lot of
trade networks throughout the Middle
Ages. And this what it's going to do
that's very profitable is that they
import spices
from
from East Asia back to Europe, okay?
And this is going to make
Venice very, very wealthy.
So, the two big cities are Genoa and
Venice, okay? And as you can see, they
are extremely energetic. They're going
to set up trade networks throughout the
world.
Um this is a spice trade, and the
center, of course, is in Venice. And
this makes Venice the most
uh
um
wealthy city in Europe at some point.
Okay. Also, remember what these um small
city-states do that's that's very
effective is that they become parasites
on the empire, okay? So, Venice can take
its wealth and bribe imperial
bureaucrats in Constantinople to give it
trade preferences. Okay?
And Venice will also set up alliances
with also the Ottoman Empire as well as
the Mongols as well.
Guess who is from Venice? Marco Polo is
from Venice, okay? Why is Marco Polo
traveling around the world to set up new
linkages for Venice?
Okay? So, you got all these Venetians
going around the world to be spies and
to explore in order to set up new
networks for Venice. Because they don't
have any choice in the matter. They are
a trading power. They don't have any
resource resources on their own, so the
people have to be very energetic.
Okay? And um while this is happening,
they set up these banks where the
wealthy merchants can pool their
resources to take more risks, okay?
>> [snorts]
>> Um eventually, what happen is that
Venice will decline and the Dutch
Republic will emerge. What makes the
Dutch Republic so powerful is that it's
ruled by merchants who now adopted
Calvinism. Okay? Remember, Calvinism is
the faith that wealth
is signals that you'll go to heaven. So,
everyone in the Dutch Republic works
really, really hard. It's a very
energetic society.
And they can now feed off the Spanish
Empire, okay? The Austrian-Hungarian
Empire Habsburgs. Why? Because the
Spanish Empire, what they've done is
they've gone to South America and
captured a lot of gold. And they And
this makes their people very lazy. Okay?
So, there are three ways in which you
can take advantage of that. The first,
of course, is piracy where your ships
just steal the gold as this gold is
heading back to Spain. Another issue is
by
providing industry for these people.
These people don't want to work, so you
just sell them clothes, okay? And this
builds up the uh industry of France,
Britain, and the Dutch Republic. The
last way, of course, is providing luxury
goods, especially spices, to the market.
So, because the Spanish Empire is so
wealthy, this wealth transfers to the
energy industry of the Dutch Republic.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay?
Um and as you can see, this is what the
trade looks like. The Dutch will set up
a private company called the Dutch East
Indies Company, which is almost like a
nation unto itself. It becomes the the
world's wealthiest corporation even
today.
Okay?
Um and the the reason why it is it has a
monopoly over the spice trade from the
East Indies. It has its own army, it has
its own currency, it has it has its own
government, okay? It can act enact its
own laws in the regions it controls.
All right.
Um and as you can see, the Dutch are
very energetic. So, as a comparison,
let's compare it to the
Spanish Empire, okay? So, at at this
point in history, the Spanish Empire is
the wealthiest, most largest empire in
the world, but as you can see, the Dutch
are much more energetic.
Okay? The Dutch are much more
industrious.
And the British are actually much more
industrious as well, okay? The reason
why is the Spanish are still Catholic,
whereas the Dutch Republic have turned
into Protestants.
Okay? And this allows for the growth of
the middle class because as long as
you're willing to work hard, you you can
become wealthy. Whereas the Spanish,
it's very much a society based on
nobility and clerical privilege. Okay?
All right.
So, as we discussed, the two leaders of
the Protestant Reformation are Martin
Luther
who proposed justification by sin by
faith, okay? Justification by faith. You
have to actually believe in God if you
want to access heaven.
And John Calvin who proposed the idea of
double predestination, which means that
God has already decided who's going
who's who's going to hell, who's going
to heaven, and therefore you have to
prove it to yourself by working really
hard, making a lot of money, and not
spending it, okay? And then all this
money goes to the bank, which allows for
the growth of the Dutch Republic.
All [snorts] right.
Um the Protestant Reformation will have
many major effects on the world. It will
lead to something called the Thirty
Years' War, and the Protestants will
fight the Catholics.
And this will lead to the death of
millions and millions of people. In
fact, this is the deadliest war in
Europe right before World War I,
okay?
Um yeah, the war is deadly, lasts for a
long time, 30 years. It will kill
millions of people.
Um
Because of the Protestant Reformation,
the Catholic Church is under attack. So,
what they decided to do is they set
decided to set up a secret society,
basically an intelligence agency, called
the Jesuits. This is Loyola. Uh you may
have have heard of Loyola University.
So, they just go around the world set up
a lot of universities and schools, but
their main mission is to infiltrate
uh Protestant societies and try to
overthrow the government and try to make
them more Catholic, okay?
In response, the So, this is the
um system of the Jesuits.
In response, the Protestants will set up
something called the Freemasons, okay?
We'll discuss this later on, right? But
so So, throughout history at this time,
there's a battle a secret battle going
on between the Jesuits and the
Freemasons. They're using all sorts of
really nefarious, evil techniques,
including, as we discussed, traumatizing
young children so they can be spies to
infiltrate other groups.
Okay? Because remember,
um
at this point in history, people believe
in God, so they're going to ask you, "Do
you swear to God?" And you have to,
okay? And so, you have to have secret
identities if you are to pass their
test.
Okay. So, one of the crucial
battlegrounds between the Jesuits and
the and the Freemasons and Protestants
is England, okay? Uh Henry VIII, what he
will do is he will split off from the
Pope because the Henry VIII, like most
monarchs in in Europe, they want to
maintain their independence, their
autonomy.
>> [snorts]
>> When he dies,
um Queen Elizabeth I will inherit the
throne. And at this point in history,
there are a lot of Catholics who want to
see her overthrown. So, she launches
this massive campaign to persecute
Catholics.
Um this will lead to many, many battles,
crises between the Catholics and the
Protestants.
Um James II is a Catholic king. is a
Catholic king, and the Protestant
nobility don't don't want that. So, what
they will do is they will conspire
against him. In 1688, they will invite
the Dutch uh aristocrat, William of
Orange,
into England to become the king. And the
And this will lead to something called
the Glorious Revolution where now
authority passes to Parliament. What
Parliament will do is
charter something called the Bank of
England, which is again, it's a private
bank with the power of state. They can
print money, okay? And this starts a
huge problem
uh because before, what happened is
these private bankers would lend money
to to monarchs. The problem with that is
the monarch could die, the monarch could
be overthrown, the monarch could lose a
war, the monarch could just decide not
to pay you back, okay? But now, if it's
Parliament that's borrowing money, the
people always have to pay you back.
Okay? Unless England is destroyed as a
nation, your
uh loan to the nation will always be
guaranteed.
And this is uh what will allow England
to become an empire. So, the great
conflict uh um between England and
France, of course, is the Napoleonic
Wars where Napoleon is about to conquer
Europe, and Britain cannot have that,
okay? Britain is a is a
naval power. And if
Napoleon is able to establish an empire
in Europe, then England won't be able to
trade with Europe. So, what England will
do is finance seven wars against
Napoleon.
And they can do that because they have
the Bank of England, which is able to
borrow unlimited amount of money from
the future as well as across space,
okay? Across time and space. That's they
were able to defeat Napoleon. Napoleon
defeated England six times.
But England didn't really care because
first of all, England wasn't fighting
the war, it was just financing the wars.
And England could not stop fighting the
wars because otherwise it would go
bankrupt, okay? Does that make sense?
>> [snorts]
>> All right, the Napoleonic Wars.
And this establishes, of course,
uh the British Empire and they do what
they want now. So, they take over
um India and they set up something
called the East India Company. Okay?
And the East India Company is also a
nation onto itself. It is at this time,
as a company, maybe the third or fourth
richest nation in the world.
And of course, what they do that's very
important is they extract wealth from
India. They basically steal a lot of
wealth from India. They People estimate
that they've stolen like 45 trillion
dollars
of wealth from India, okay? So, you can
see how in 1700, before the arrival of
the East India Company, India might have
like a quarter of the world's GDP, but
over the next 200 300 years,
their wealth will plummet, okay? The
reason why is what's going to happen is
that England will turn India into a
resource colony. They will destroy the
manufacturing base of India, turn it to
an agricultural economy, and then force
India to buy British manufactured goods,
okay? So, what they will do is use India
to
um
drive their Industrial Revolution.
Okay? And as you can see, they're also
forcing Indians to pay a lot more money
than their own people.
>> [snorts]
>> And so, in 1913,
um
to 1950, the average income of Indians
don't really change that much, okay? But
what's really important for you to
understand is this.
The British couldn't have done this
wealth help from the Indian people
themselves, okay? So, what's happening
is the British, with the Bank of
England, they're able to co-opt the
Indian elite. Why? Because now you're
able to take your wealth and then store
it in England.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
Before,
um you couldn't really take your wealth
anywhere, so so your interests were
aligned with the people. But now that
you're able to take this wealth and then
put it in England to be safe, your
interests are now aligned with the
British.
And guess what, guys? The same strategy
happened in China as well, where the
Chinese local elites were helping the
British establish opium trade networks
throughout the country. That's why opium
was able to spread so fast, okay?
And
guys, the system the system is still
around today, okay? So, the British
Empire may be gone, but the British
system of money laundering,
of
um stealing a nation's resources by
co-opting their elite,
it still exists today, okay? So, these
are all places where England has these
offshore private banks so that the elite
of Africa, of Asia can take can steal
from the nation and store it in these
banks.
Okay?
All right, so England has some of the
world's worst tax havens.
>> [snorts]
>> All right.
So, what did England do with this money?
Well, what England did was invest it in
America.
At this time, America is
industrializing.
And what's interesting about America is
only a few individuals were able to
monopolize entire industries. This is
Cornelius Vanderbilt and he monopolized
the railroad industry. How did he do
that?
This is Andrew Carnegie, who was born
poor, but then he monopolized America's
steel industry.
How did How did one person do that?
That's really strange, guys.
Oh, Rockefeller, he monopolized
America's oil industry. In fact, over 6
weeks he was able to buy all his
competitors. Where did he get all this
money to buy all his competitors? How
did he become a monopolist? How is this
happening, guys?
J.P. Morgan, he monopolizes
um America's financial industry and he
creates something called the Federal
Reserve, which is which is a system that
is still up today, where America's ruled
by private banks.
Okay? How's this happening?
All right, so these questions. How's it
possible for these individuals to
monopolize industries? Why are these
monopolies national rather than
regional, okay? And why didn't
government make public these critical
infrastructure and resource like like we
do in China, right? Oil should belong to
people. Why does it belong to one
person? The reason why is
it is England that is using its wealth
from India and China to finance these
individuals and allow these individuals
to buy up entire industries. Why is it
doing that? Because the the Americans at
this history at this time in history,
they hate the British, right? They
Americans are like, in 1776 we fought a
revolution with the British. Why would
we allow the British come back and buy
up our land and our oil and our steel
and our railroads, right? Therefore,
they needed people like John D.
Rockefeller and Andrew Carnegie to act
as their agents, okay? Does that make
sense? All right. So, in America you're
taught that these people, uh Andrew
Carnegie, John D. Rockefeller, they were
just rags to riches. It's because of the
American dream. It's a lot of
opportunity. If you work hard, you can
become a billionaire. No, guys, that's
not true, okay? If you belong to a
secret society, if you are financed by
the British Empire, you could become a
billionaire.
And guess what, guys?
We have the same system today. Bill
Gates, hm.
Hm. Mark Zuckerberg, really strange.
This 19-year-old guy drops out from
Harvard and founds Facebook, okay? And
now he's a billionaire. HOW DOES THAT
HAPPEN, GUYS?
WELL, IT MUST BE THE AMERICAN DREAM.
OH,
CHATGPT, GUYS.
Really strange.
If you have a dream and you just follow
it, you can become a billionaire in
America.
Yeah.
>> Yeah.
It's all just a scam, right?
Google, it's all just a scam, okay? What
you need to understand about these
companies is
they were all founded with US military
technology that is public, okay? The
internet, it's a US military technology.
Google, the search engines, it's all US
military technology. They were given to
these guys for free.
Why would they do that?
Okay? Again,
if you think that we're ruled by secret
societies
and it's really secret
societies that control the world and
they want this technology out there to
to better surveil people, it makes a lot
more sense, right? Because if the
Pentagon said, "Hey, we have this free
computer that you can use." You'd be
like, "I'm not going to use this
computer cuz you're spying on me,
right?" But if Mark Zuckerberg says,
"Hey, free Facebook, guys. You want to
use it?" YOU'RE LIKE, "YEAH, SURE.
FACEBOOK, YEAH. He's a dork from
Harvard. Of course he can be trusted."
Right? Same Same strategy, okay, guys?
>> [snorts]
>> All right, so 1913,
these bankers met together to set up the
Federal Reserve system.
And this led to something called the
Bretton Woods system in 1945. America
won the war and America promised the
world that
the US currency, backed by gold, will
become
the reserve currency of the world.
But the US currency will always be
backed by gold, therefore you don't need
to worry about it, right?
Well,
in 1971, Richard Nixon says, "Screw
that, okay?
We're not backed by by gold anymore. By
We're not backed by gold anymore. You
can use it. You don't You don't have to
use it, though, okay? But guess what?
Oil will will now be sold in gold in US
dollars, okay? This is called the
petrodollar. So, if you want to buy oil,
you have to use US dollars, okay?
And then he did something else that was
very important, in fact even more
important
uh than
uh linking the US dollar to
oil. Can you guys guess what?
Oh, this.
Okay?
Guess what?
Um millions of Chinese working really
hard, it's all for useless US dollars,
guys, okay?
All right. Okay, so
America was founded by Ben Franklin and
George Washington, among others. They
were both members of the Freemasons.
They were both members of secret
societies.
Okay? So, America is really a Freemason
um country. And how do we know? Look at
Washington D.C., okay?
Guess what, guys? The architecture, the
city design, it's all secret society
stuff, okay? This is a pentagram and
this is the White House, right?
This is the White House.
And
you can see how it's designed. This is
occult symbolism.
>> [snorts]
>> This is another picture showing you that
this is the Freemason symbol, backed by
the Pentagon. Oh, sorry, the pentagram,
okay?
Okay?
If you want to see more of these secret
societies' occult symbolism, just look
at look at the US money.
All right, this is the all-seeing eye,
the pyramid. It all All of the symbolism
comes from Egypt, Greece, Babylon, okay?
It's all part of the Freemason
um system.
This is seal of the United States.
The new world order, okay? The new world
order.
We'll be discussing this next week.
Okay, but now you reach a point in
history where you've got too much
wealth, people become lazy and
complacent. So, what do you do with
these peasants? We know exactly what
they're going to do. They're going to
screw the economy like they did in 1929,
and then they're going to start
World War III, okay?
That's the That's the goal. Because how
the system works is if you're trying to
stash your capital, you need people to
constantly focus
on working.
Okay, and you do that by creating
anxiety, by destroying wealth,
by creating a cycle of constant death
and destruction.
All right? Any questions?
Clear, guys?
All right. So, um, great. So, next class
we will discuss
um, the sampling of francus, okay? All
right.